if you're doing this world technique you
typically want to start from your
natural growth pattern
and
wrap it
so it always starts
and leads back to the front what's
happening it's your man the marcus
harvey the barber star once again it's
on and what are we here to do today
learn how to get the waves get the waves
for the base you know how they be like
oh you got waves oh you got away like
yeah i got waves girl oh let me set your
ways no you can't touch my waves girl
that's what i'm about to teach y'all how
to get that type of feel going on so
let's get to it
so what are waves ways are the training
of your curly hair to be laid down in a
wave pattern so there's many different
wave patterns 180 is the one that i have
why is it called the 180 it's because i
have a fade with my waves
other people who have this dope type of
haircut nas also my guy drake he's fly
with it the most popular wave pattern is
the 360 waves this is something that we
all had as a kid except ferg has it
mike rainey has it p diddy jaylen rose
shouts out to my guy andy often if
you're keeping that haircut tight
there's also the 540 and the 720 which
are very very rare only person that i
know who's had the 720 was probably last
cause i'm talking about lance was
brushing that thing from over here he
was coming from the back like
we're going to be walking down the whole
process of getting your ways together
the things you're going to need to
optimize your waves a brush
do-rag
shampoo conditioner moisturizing
products
and you got to have a dope barber shouts
out to my barber donato he got me fresh
y'all just let's look at man
oh you saw me two over there okay
step one prepare and wash your hair now
there's been a big myth out there in the
world that you can over shampoo your
hair yes if you're not putting in
product to add moisture back in but in
this process we're going to be adding
moisture in multiple steps so you can
never over shampoo your hair can never
over condition your hair especially when
you want to get optimum waves so i
suggest that you shampoo three times a
week and every day condition your hair
while you're in the shower just so that
you can make sure that your hair is at
its optimum softness get rid of any
built up product that was in from the
day before and i know that my hair is
going to be soft
manageable and just going to be obedient
to my brush so once you have a healthy
scalp it is imperative that you find the
right barber now the right barber is
going to set up the parameters of your
ways you're going to go through a
process called woofing whooping is
growing your hair out to
crazy lengths but still brushing your
hair in the wave pattern that you want
it to be now this process can be as long
as months
as long as weeks the longer you're
making letting them things wolf
the deeper your waves can be
step two
moisturizing so the most common things
that keep you from having your hair wavy
is not moisturizing your hair leaving
your hair being dry does not allow it to
be
trained right so
wet dry memory is the thing that gets
your hair to allowing it to be able to
do what it needs to do to give you the
wave pattern so the more moisture you
have in your hair the more manageable it
is the more it obeys your commands the
more it lays down now this is very
important because once you get out the
shower you want to leave your hair just
damp you don't want to go ahead and dry
it all the way up you do not want to do
that you want to leave your hair damp
that way that when you use the product
it can actually go through your hair
smoothly as we talked about before wet
dry memory when you use the product it
kind of falls into place with the way
you're going to brush your hair so let
me show you how to do it since my hair
is dry but it's clean i'm going to go
ahead and just dampen my hair with a
little spray bottle very simple
so when you have thicker hair more
coarse hair you want to use a product
that's more of a bomb more of a scalp
butter a wave butter you already know
there's always that old school red can
that you can get on that gold can but we
know it's too thick for your hair you
want to make sure that your hair is
actually breathing your scalp is healthy
you do not want to have something that
clogs up your pores so make sure that
it's either water-based or it has a very
good butter base to it so that it can
actually not clog up your pores i like
using cold labels wave butter as well as
bevels beard balm it's a great product
it actually doubles as a beard balm as
well as a pomade gives you a nice light
hold allows you to really get your ways
shiny
shiny so let me go ahead and show you
how we do it
a little
dimes worth nickels worth of
product in my hand emulsify it in my
hands
when i get out the shower i like to do
this process like this it kind of almost
dries the hair
as well as kind of gives you a nice
booster because the oils from your hand
as well as the heat from your hand lays
down the waves so it kind of gives it a
nice little
as you can see already just it's just me
just rubbing through my hair putting the
brush so then
as i've applied it put a little bit of
the the same
a nickel's worth of the beard balm
emotified in your hands everybody finds
their own technique in hack
this has been mine for years
now with me having 180 waves as you can
see i just applied it on the top but if
you want 360 waves and you want it all
the way around your hair you literally
do that same process around
right where the waves are and do the
same
application you're making sure that you
put ample ample pressure the more you
like lay your hair down with your hands
the heat from your hands
helps and aids in the waves development
all right so now that i probably did
that about 60 to 80 times
you always want to go with the grain on
your waves never want to go against grin
ladies
let me let me this is a sidebar for you
ladies
if your man has waves
please don't go against the grain
brushing it or putting your hands to it
oh no that's that's causes for breakup
you're not getting a valentine's day
gift if you push against my waves
step 3 brushing your hair
as we all know the brushing technique is
the only technique that you can do all
day long
i like to get a medium bristled brush
typically boar's hair type of situation
definitely want to make sure that the
bristles are close together you don't
want to get a brush that has very wide
gaping lines depending on how long your
hair is depends on how hard you want
your bristles to be if you have very
very coarse hair and your hair is really
long in the whooping process you might
want to use a hard bristle brush i
typically like to use the medium
bristled brushes but you must
always brush your hair
at least a minimum of four to five times
a day if you want to make your waves
really really pop you have to be
committed to it that strongly there's
two types of wave at the beehive and the
swirl so if you're doing the beehive
versus the swirl the beehive typically
starts from the natural growth pattern
and all you do is just go straight down
all the way around
straight down and that is the beehive if
you're doing this world technique you
typically want to start from your
natural growth pattern
and
wrap it
so it always starts
and leads back to the front this is how
lance brushes his hair
and a lot of people who have
that type of texture
and then they just
kind of brush it like that it's
definitely more at an angle
and you definitely want to make sure
that the brush is
resting on the hair strand and not
scraping the scalp that just ruined all
that work i just got done doing
now let's go back to the way i brush it
the regular standard
beehive with the 180 in one direction so
typically everybody has their own rhythm
in which they brush their hair i like to
do things in hundreds so i like to
always do like 100 strokes of the brush
over my hair
just so that i can make sure that it's
laid down
and looking exactly the way i want it to
look when i bring it out the do-rag
step 4 the do-rag
you read the do-rag when you're going to
work when you get out the shower and
then when you take a shower going to bed
you do the same process over again you
might not want to tie it as tight but
you want to make sure that it's secure
so that at night while you're sleeping
it's still locking in the moisture and
it's still training your hair strand to
do exactly what you wanted to do which
is wave up and like i said before you
want to always make sure
that
your hair is still damp before you put
your do-rag on all right so there are
several different types of dual rags you
have velvet a silk polyester blend which
is the type that i typically like to use
because it locks in moisture
it also holds the waves in place
and it allows you to keep the
pattern that you just got done brushing
and rubbing into your head laying it
down and establishing and holding it
there so it can bake
all right i like to put my do-rag on
inside out
this is the number one thing you want to
make sure that the lining is on the
outside because if you have it on the
inside you'll have a line in the middle
of your hair so you always want to make
sure that the hem is on the outside i
like to have my hands underneath it so
that it doesn't disturb whatever i
brushed
and then like to place it right over
your eyebrows
now this is the way that you tie it so
that you don't get a line
brothers have been getting lines from
their durags for years
you got to actually use the way that the
do-rag is cut
so they're making wider
joints now so what do i do
keep it wide
right over my eyebrows
and then you tie it in the back
like a shoe
second portion you pull out so that it
pulls the hair down you also adjust the
ties
underneath your occipital bone
[Music]
and you pull
the front part
as well as the back part where the hem
is
and you pull opposite directions to make
it tighter
once you do that and then you roll it up
right there
all right
that's for the front
now you always have this left over in
the back what i like to do is roll it
again and then tie it in the back like a
shoe again and that's
how you apply your do-rag
without getting a line now typically the
reason why you get a lot is because you
would make sure that
the ties would be too thin
and all that pressure would just go
right on that spot so when you're
widening it
with the strand it applies the pressure
all the way around here so it doesn't
give you
that
do rag on sometimes you don't get a run
in your durag but that's because you
want to keep it tight
get many do-rags
because you will instead of running this
thing to get them away and that might
have just been one of my ways of saying
i got to get out now but you want to
keep your do-rag on
for at least 30 minutes
this allows your hair to dry underneath
it like we said before wet dry memory
allows your wave pattern to know exactly
what it's going to do so you want to
keep this on until your hair actually
dries this whole process is right after
the shower so you can get dressed fix
you a cup of coffee get in the car
drive halfway to work and then what i
like to do
is i like to unleash
one level which is the front level
i untie that
and then i let that go five minutes
before you about to pull it to work and
then i just let it kind of breathe and
that that does is just allows whatever
indention that was created on the right
right over to kind of work its way back
and then just let that thing go
pull up to work all right all right
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
y'all got to send the coast guard out
for this
the fifth and final step consistency
consistency is the key to allowing your
waves to be unleashed
the more consistent you are with this
technique brushing moisturizing shampoo
and conditioning do rag in your hair the
better your ways are going to be i'm
going to tap back in with y'all in two
weeks and let you see what consistent
brushing moisturizing do-dragon gets you
[Music]
i am your man the marcus harvey the
barber star and i'm here to tell you why
not be fresh why because clean never
goes out of style we're here at the
moosa lair come tap in with us i'm a
good barber you know other good barbers
here shout out to donato you got me
fresh bro we'll see you next time gq
yeah